[Music]
it's that time again
sony have revealed the free games of our
playstation plus subscribers
for the month of january 2021. like
usual we can grab these games from the
first tuesday of the month which this
time is january
the 5th this month three games across
ps4 and ps5
let's start with the ps5 title man eater
if you've ever wanted to be a shark in a
video game now it's your chance
manita is a single player rpg of sorts
in which we begin life as a small
shark pup who evolves over time to
become the ultimate apex predator
taking down fish gators dolphins whales
and of course those pesky humans with an
open world full of easter eggs and
secrets to discover
this is not something to be ignored
please try this give it an hour and i
promise you will fall in love with
manita and if you play long enough
you'll evolve
in some strange and unprecedented ways
as you track down scaly pete at the
infamous shark hunter
sadly you can't play this on ps4 this is
just for the ps5
fan on the ps4 though we have shadow of
the tomb raider
following on from 2015's rise of the
tomb raider reboot
shadow continues her new adventures the
cartoon raider elements are here with
puzzle solving and action
constantly on offer but this time the
gameplay has been adjusted after
feedback from
fans swimming elements have been added
and more intense fighting mechanics and
difficulty settings too
ign gave shadow of the tomb raider a
massive 9 out of 10 score with most
other reviewers saying it's more like a
7.5 out of 10
which isn't too shabby at all so if
you're into third person action
adventure games
give lara some love this january and
finally
an rpg this is greed fall not to be
confused with the ps5 title
godfall greed fall is set in the 17th
century
as we witness settlers fighting off
invading forces
things take a turn for the supernatural
with strange beings appearing but most
of this game is completely grounded in
reality
the world is completely open the more we
explore the more missions we find and
the more battles we undertake
and the tactical nature of battles is an
area which saw great praise in the
reviews back in 2019.
it's even possible to pause mid-fight to
analyze the battlefield for the best
course of action
overall what do you think a pretty good
lineup i reckon the next time we meet up
we'll have a brand new game to talk
about which is going straight into ps
plus in february
more on that soon and remember ps plus
gives you more than the free games each
month
ps plus opens the multiplayer portion of
many games
including destiny 2 hey segway destiny 2
on ps5 revamps the game with 120 frames
per second in pvp matches
and 4k 60fps support elsewhere
you can pick up the base game for free
in the psn store right now and
should you like it there is a massive
discount on the latest expansion beyond
light
and many other dlcs too there's a link
in the description if you want it i also
made a video breaking down
everything you need to know and it's on
screen right now look at it
thank you bunji for sponsoring this ps
plus update and thank you for watching
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure all the best for 2021
see ya